THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANKS, CAPTAIN, THANK YOU,
STERLING.
PEOPLE WATCH "PRIMETIME" FOR ONE
REASON AND ONE REASON ONLY.
AND NO, IT'S NOT FOR JOHNNY.
IT'S BECAUSE WE GET RESULTS.
WE GOT PAULIE P.'S DASH CAM
VIDEO.
GOT JOE BIDEN TO CALL DESANTIS
AHEAD OF THE HURRICANE.
AND GOT AOC TO GET OFF SOCIAL
MEDIA AND GO BACK TO WORK.
WELL, TONIGHT, WE ARE PUTTING
ANOTHER FEATHER IN THE OLD
"PRIMETIME" CAP.
THIS TIME IN THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN.
SO LAST NIGHT WE TORE INTO
WAUKESHA CHRISTMAS PARADE KILLER
DARRELL BROOKS FOR HIS
RIDICULOUS BEHAVIOR DURING THIS
MURDER TRIAL.
HE HAS TAKEN OFF HIS CLOTHES AND
CHANGED HIS NAME AND FIGHTING
WITHENS WITHS, LAWYERS, EVEN THE
JUDGE.
WE SAID SOMEONE HAS TO PUT A
STOP TO IT.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
SOMEONE DID.
JUDGE JENNIFER DARR ROW MUST
HAVE BEEN WATCHING THE SHOW LAST
NIGHT.
BECAUSE SHE TOSSED BROOKS OUT OF
COURT THIS MORNING AFTER ANOTHER
OUTBURST.
WATCH.
>> YES.
>> JUST ONE?
>> TWO.
>> MR. BROOKS, YOU ARE ADVISED
TO STOP WITH THE COMMENTARY.
>> NO I'M GOING TO SAY WHAT I
WANT TO SAY.
>> YOU CALLED THIS WITNESS.
I'M GOING TO TAKE A BREAK RIGHT
NOW AND EXCUSE THE JURY AND THIS
WITNESS.
>> ALL RISE.
>> WHAT SHE IS DOING IS JUDICIAL
MISCONDUCT.
IT'S JUDICIAL MISCONDUCT.
>> MR. BROOKS, PLEASE STOP.
>> THERE AIN'T NO PLEASE
NOTHING.
>> YOU ARE DISRUPTIVE.
>> FIND SOME REASON TO SAY
SOMEONE IS BEING DISRUPTIVE
BECAUSE THEY WANT THE TRUTH TO
BE OUT THERE.
MAN, QUIT IT.  YOU ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE THE JUDGE.
>> MR. BROOKS, I'M ADVISING YOU
THAT CONTINUED INTERRUPTIONS
WILL RESULT NEW YOUR RIGHT TO BE
PRESENT IN THIS COURTROOM.
>> WHAT LAW CAN YOU DO THAT.
>> ILLINOIS VS. ALLEN.
>> THE FOURTH OPTION YOU MADE UP
THAT'S NOT EVEN IN THE LAW?
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
>> I NEED TO MAKE A RULING.
>> BY LAW, YOU CAN'T DO AND THIS
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING TO EXCUSE EVERYONE.
MR. BROOKS IS BEING REMOVED FROM
THE COURTROOM.
HE WILL CONTINUE IN THE
NEIGHBORING COURTROOM.
>> Jesse: GREAT JOB BY JUDGE
DURRO.
I'M SURE SHE PROBABLY DIDN'T SEE
ME SAYING THEY SHOULD KICK THE
GUY OUT OF COURT.
IT'S JUS